what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the adventures of Jonathan
Kent in the Injustice Universe the thing
about this is that this picks up much
like the last few issues that we saw
with the son of Superman Jonathan in the
Injustice Universe remember he's
displaced in an alternate reality now
what ends up happening is Injustice
Superman comes in and while he initially
allows Jonathan quote unquote the tour
of the world meaning Jonathan can travel
around and he can see what the world is
like under the control of Superman
Jonathan started to realize that people
follow the rules and they follow the
rule of law because they're scared of
the consequences now when Superman comes
in he basically talks about how Sinestro
and those guys had effectively picked up
on a disturbance in the moon which
really leads Superman and his guys to go
investigate this takes Jonathan by
surprise that Superman would Ally
himself with sinestra now let's talk
about this for a second because this is
kind of a cool thing now Sinestro when
he initially appeared in the Injustice
Universe he almost showed up as a kind
of Mentor for Superman right bonding
with him talking about how he
understands the loss of a world but have
no Illusions Sinestro was not a good guy
he was not a a villain turned hero
understanding the error of his ways he
was a manipulator and by every sense of
the word he saw Superman as a means to
achieve his own end which was to take
revenge against the Guardians of the
universe and even the full-scale
destruction of the Green Lanterns so
much so that when Sinestro first pops up
he and the Sinestro core tear Kyle
Rainer to Pieces it's pretty gruesome
and so him being here and allied with
Superman it's more Superman being
manipulated than anything else but the
other part of this is that Jonathan kind
of musing to himself and talking about
what's going on he really kind of
discusses or at least has this inner
monologue about how terrifying this
world is right he says this is a
nightmare this world this Justice League
I want to go home but I don't know how
and I can't go home and leave this earth
the way that it is I simply just can't
but then he ends up spotting Lex Luthor
now Lex Luthor was kind of one of these
characters in Injustice where he and
Superman were sort of friends in the
very very beginning and then as Superman
became tyrannical Lex Luthor sort of
worked against him as more of a spy than
anything else like a double agent he was
really working for Batman and so when
Jonathan follows Luther Luther basically
arrives out there where Batman and his
forces are located and Jonathan follows
suit now of course as soon as Jonathan
shows up here Batman's immediately on
the attack with all of his forces now
one of the reasons this happens and for
those of you guys who are familiar with
Batman it seems very uncharacteristic
that Batman would just attack first and
then ask questions later that's the
point of Injustice right under any
normal circumstance Batman would really
ask like why are you here in this
instance he literally says don't let him
leave and like they immediately all
attacked Jonathan like they immediately
all sees on and now of course Jonathan
helps these guys understand their place
in the bigger picture quite readily the
reason why Batman responds the way he
does is because the nature of Injustice
changed Bruce Wayne it changed how he
operated because in a lot of ways he saw
Superman even though he never really
admitted it per se because you know
Bruce Wayne is it's like the most stoic
guy ever right he never talks about his
feelings but but with his character he
always saw Superman as kind of the
greatest of them but to see the greatest
of them fall so far and to really be
Beyond Redemption it just kind of
destroyed whatever trust Bruce Wayne
could and really did have towards
anybody so he doesn't really trust
anyone at all and they're really the
reason why they're all so strong is
because what we ended up finding out in
Injustice is that there was a pill that
was developed that would basically allow
those individuals who consumed it to
possess the powers of Superman at least
strength speed different things like
that but the thing here is remember
Jonathan has a kind of secret power that
DC has not really explained yet it's
something they've been teasing for quite
some time that in moments of high duress
that Jonathan just kind of manifests
this extreme level of power and then
suddenly everybody's basically defeated
in that moment and that's exactly what
happens right Batman Catwoman Harley
Quinn like they're all just kind of sent
fly but then Barbara Gordon Batgirl
steps in now the thing about this is
that where you initially have Jonathan
that tells her to stop it takes her by
surprise that he knows her name and this
is why Jonathan as a character is so
cool and Injustice because this is
really a universe where basically
everyone's lost their way in all these
different superheroes just became the
darkest version of themselves and so one
of the things that he says is where
she's surprised and she's like you know
my name his response is yes right in my
universe you and Nightwing are very very
close right you guys are exceedingly
close more so than that you and the bat
family are nothing like this and so he
literally says like I just want to
understand what's been happening here
and I want to help if I can enter Alfred
pennyworth now Alfred is kind of like
this one last remaining Bastion of
Happiness to a degree don't
misunderstand that right Alfred's got it
where it counts in fact there's one
point where he consumed one of those
pills and then just like head-butted
Superman into Oblivion it was amazing
Alfred beat the crap out of Superman
I'll have a link to the Injustice
playlist down in the comment section so
you guys can get caught up on it all
it's it's such an amazing story it's so
phenomenal the way it goes down but once
it all all kind of calms down and Alfred
steps in you basically have really
Jonathan listening to what everybody has
to say and what Luther does is he says I
know how bad this looks and when
Jonathan says it looks like you're
planning to take down Superman by
stealing technology from a course the
response of Luther is okay yeah it is
every bit as bad as you think it is
right now the corpse they're talking
about is Ultraman the Superman of Earth
3 who had made his way into Injustice
and that's what kind of caused all this
in the first place what we didn't
necessarily know and even Luther's kind
of figuring it out whenever Ultraman
went to a different universe that had a
Superman in it there was a kind of
object or something within him that
basically neutralized the powers or at
least weakened the powers of that
version of Kalel right that universe's
version of Superman it didn't affect
anybody else it only affected Superman
and of course that would lead to
Ultraman killing that Superman then the
Earth would fall shortly after because
there would be no one on Superman's
level to protect it and so the result to
this is that in order to defeat the
unjust Justice Superman that Lex Luthor
has this kind of device right he
basically looks at this analyzes it and
says this seems to be something that we
could use in order to defeat Superman
now in a lot of ways if you're familiar
with Injustice this is all kind of a
foregone conclusion by and large we
really just kind of know that it doesn't
work just because of the fact the things
that are going on in this story in
relation to the Injustice Universe sure
you could make it fit in but we already
know how Injustice ends we already know
how that story concludes and this has
nothing to do with it so it's a really
really cool instance where we know it'll
happen but it is still kind of a cool
story to follow and so once all this
information is divulged Luther and
Batman tell Jonathan like we really need
your help and that's when Jonathan says
you want me to fight against my father
now of course Batman chimes in as the
voice of reason this is yes but he's not
your dad right could you really imagine
that version of Superman being your
father would your father be the kind of
Superman that would basically Force the
world subjugated into following laws as
opposed to Leading it into a brighter
tomorrow and that's when Jonathan just
kind of has to to accept yeah okay there
are huge differences there but it's also
Jonathan trying to understand both sides
of this equation because we're Lois
chimes in and says look you have to
understand that the Joker drugged and
then tricked Superman into killing his
wife and his unborn child their response
to Jonathan is and I bet Batman the best
friend of Superman was the moral support
he needed in that moment in time I bet
he was there just like a best friend
should be weren't you Batman of course
this is asked sarcastically because
Batman wasn't in that moment when
Superman was falling hard and fast when
he was falling down because everything
that he had valued in the world had been
totally destroyed what he didn't need
was a friend brow beating him over the
head with his mistakes standing there
like some kind of disapproving parent
with their arms on their hips saying why
would you do that you shouldn't do that
Superman what he needed was someone to
be in his Corner what he needed was
someone who could emotionally talk him
down because when you look at Injustice
and you look past all the extraneous
fluff all the crazy fights and all the
deaths and all those oh my God what in
the world is going on kind of moments
right when you get past all of that it's
a story about a guy who lost the things
that are most important to him and now
he's just grieving and trying to cope
with things as best he can that's
literally it it's just a sad man crying
out that's all Injustice is and the
point of Jonathan is you Bruce Wayne
should have recognized that you should
have seen that you should have known
better but the fact that you responded
in kind shows that you are not the Bruce
Wayne that I know and you're no hero
you're both screw-ups and you're both
doing things wrong it's a phenomenal
argument to make because the reality
here is it's true it's the exact same
argument that Superman from the main DC
Universe would have made as well and so
what Jonathan says is I understand where
you guys are coming from and I
understand the point that you're making
but the reality here is I'm not going to
just jump into a fight without
investigating a little bit more and so
what he does is he leaves both groups
behind that Jonathan realizes Batman is
so entrenched with the idea that he's
right that if Jonathan asks him what's
your view on all this Batman's gonna
paint himself as a good guy and he's
going to paint Superman as the villain
conversely Superman is so convinced that
he's right that if Jonathan asks him
what do you think about all this he's
going to do the exact same thing but the
opposite right pointing at Batman is the
bad guy making himself look like the
good guy so what he does is he leaves it
all behind and he basically goes to see
if the one person he trusts the most in
the world is actually alive out there in
this world that what he does is he goes
to visit Jay Nakamura now J Nakamura is
actually uh Jonathan Kim's boyfriend in
the main DC Universe yes Jonathan has a
boyfriend the crazy comic book fans got
all pissed off when that happened like
this is a kid that can fly he's got heat
vision he can survive in the vacuum of
space on his own this is the thing that
you choose to get mad about
but the thing about this is that Jay is
like the one guy Jonathan trusts more so
than that Jay isn't really allied with
any one particular side he doesn't
really support support the side of
Superman he doesn't support the side of
Batman he's just a guy who's caught in
the middle and that's the person that
you want to talk to you don't want to
talk to the guys who are fighting on
each side and they're just totally
entrenched in whether or not they are
right you want to talk to the ones who
are caught in the middle right who don't
really care about either side they just
want to live their life and so as he
starts talking to Jay the two of them
kind of Converse and Jonathan basically
admits hey like we're together in an
alternate reality and that kind of thing
and Jay comes forward and says this
world sucks man it's a really crappy
place like yes Superman is really just
kind of running this world as a
dictatorship that man makes himself look
like a good guy but I can't tell you how
many innocent people get caught in the
crossfire I can't tell you how many
innocent people have been killed because
of the various fights that These two
factions have had against each other and
the reality here is their role as
superheroes has been lost now all the
innocent people out there who die are
collateral damage and while Batman sings
his sad little songs about the value of
human life and all that kind of stuff he
doesn't really seem to care too much
when it all comes down to these innocent
people being killed because he shuffles
all the blame off on Superman and says
if you hadn't done what you've done then
none of these people would have died in
the first place right whereas Jay kind
of looks around and says this it doesn't
need to be this way and so it's a really
interesting point because Jonathan says
I know exactly what it is that I need to
do I know exactly what it is that I have
to do here's the problem the entire time
this was happening Jonathan had
previously met with Damian Wayne and
where Damian Wayne was is really just
kind of been with Superman the entire
time he's also keeping an eye on
Jonathan now again in the made DC
Universe Jonathan and Damian are the
best of friends in this universe Damien
doesn't trust him one because Jonathan
doesn't exist and two because Jonathan
coming here from an alternate reality
he's not Allied directly with Superman
and honestly Damien just distrusts
everybody and so in the initial
conversation that they'd had Damien had
slapped a tracking device on Jonathan
and so once Jonathan leaves the
apartment of Jay Damien immediately
shows up here and goes after Jay and
says tell me what it is the two of you
guys talked about or I'm gonna kill you
here on the spot with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace